invaded my privacy attacked my wife
Hunter Biden the son of Joe Biden and
Joe loves this boy you must know that he
really loves him that's what they tell
us on The View every day uh he was on
Capitol Hill yesterday explaining that
everything going on with him and his
business dealings and his father and a
potential impending impeachment is
really because Maga is a bunch of crazy
people for six years Maga Republicans
including members of the House
committees who are in a closed door
session session right
now have imped my
character invaded my privacy attacked my
wife my children my family and my
friends they ridiculed my struggle with
addiction they belittled my
recovery and they have tried to
dehumanize me all to embarrass and
damage my
father who has do devoted his entire
public life to
service God I I just looked at Connor my
D It's funny everyone's body language
right now because I just looked at
Connor in my director in the middle of
that and I always forget if you guys are
muted if we're all muted during these
things because all look Ron's crying we
were all laughing hysterically through
that unfortunately everyone was muted I
may have to change how we do that going
forward my favorite part of that uh
these Maga people have imped the
character of the man who was looking for
crack cocaine out of the carpet to smoke
like parmesan cheese Ron as a
former how can you kill this man's
struggle with with substance
addiction that's really vicious of you I
can't believe it Ron I didn't mean to
interrupt you wron go ahead I'm what
exactly is the qu I mean there I can
land anywh it's just the the sheer
lunacy of everything no matter what
light they shine on why did this guy
have a job at barisma and he had no
business working at an energy company
and who is he giving the money to and
the dad firing them this is all just
about Maga and they're being mean
because you know they're not paying
enough for his artwork or something Mr
chairman as an Italian American I resent
your question about the
Mafia That's I mean this is th this is
just so transparent and it feeds into
into you know into the the yenta class
you know over at at at at the view and
and those kind of nonsense people I mean
everything is a game everything is a
spin there you know this is all his way
of saying I'm not going to answer
questions that I'm legally obligated
under a subpoena to answer and that
people have gone to
prison not only within our lifetimes
within the last several months for not
for not obeying I'm a Biden I'm separate
I want to show you something else uh
that's really just incredible so the New
York Times was covering the very press
conference that Hunter Biden was having
right there and I want to show you
listen to Hunter Biden talk about his
father's involvement or not involvement
first and then I want to show you the
way the New York Times covered it so
check the video first I am
here let me State as clearly as I
can my father was not financially
involved in my
business now I want to show you
something read the words that the New
York Times put in their quote you're
going to have to pay close attention
here we're going to show you the video
again the New York Times this is how
they covered it I am here let me State
as clearly as I can my father was not
involved in my business now we're going
to play the video for you again and see
if you can figure out what word the New
York Times left out of that quote I am
here let me State as clearly as I
can my father was not financially
involved in my
business you see what the New York Times
Did there they took the word financially
out in the quote so the average person
reading the paper wouldn't see
financially now it might be true to some
extent in the most sort of like strict
legal sense that Joe Biden was not
involved financially meaning that he
didn't write the contracts and
everything but was he you know the
contract that say got Hunter Biden the
job at barisma but was he involved
financially in The Meta sense like why
did Hunter have the job in the first
place of course he was involved
financially we know that there are also
Financial records of Hunter Biden paying
Joe Biden money and Joe Biden then using
some of the money to say Hunter bite in
this freaking house in Delaware and all
all of the
stuff